au coeur de la méditerranée et l'île de
djerba semble être comme suspendu dans
le temps
première destination touristique du pays
celle qu'on appelle djerba la douce
attire chaque année pas moins d'un
million de touristes charmer par ses
plages de sable blanc son architecture
pittoresque c'est maison berbère ou
encore ses fresques murales depuis le
début de la crise du corona virus
l'effervescence de lille a laissé place
à des rues désertes des hôtels fermés ou
encore des magasins privés de clients un
secteur touristique à l'arrêt alors que
doit s'ouvrir prochainement la saison
estivale un coup dur pour les
professionnels du tourisme qui s'était à
peine remis des attentats de 2015
cette année on pourra pas parler d'une
discuter d'une saison estivale parce
qu'on n'aura pas vraiment une
une saison on va essayer de sauver ce
qu'on peut sauver de la saison il ya des
demandes mais des réservations concrètes
on n'a pas j'ai vécu les trois
appartements qu'il ya eu pendant cette
dernière décennie en 2011 avec la
révolution après 2015
c'était moins dur après les attentats de
sousse et cette année la banque afin de
sauver les meubles
hôtels com maison d'hôtes ont dû mettre
en place un protocole sanitaires
strictes dictées par le ministère de la
santé et l'office national du tourisme
dans cette maison d'hôtes niché au coeur
de lille
les mesures sanitaires sont prises très
au sérieux de quoi rassurer personnel et
clients chaque client qu'elle arrive
trois heures avant l'arrivée on fait une
dixième 10e factions pour donner les la
propiété majorité des virus et non ma
lentille appelé on a même eu dans notre
formation mais on a changé le monde et
travailler d'exemple on prépare
est directement dans le plastique sont
tous là v à 90° et n'est permis des plus
hauts à voir des bacs terre secteur clé
de l'économie tunisienne le tourisme
représente 8 à 14% du pib national avec
pas moins de quatre cent mille emplois à
la mairie de djerba on se veut rassurant
en promettant de garantir la sécurité
des visiteurs tout en respectant un
protocole sanitaire street en
collaboration avec les autorités et les
professionnels du tourisme
nous sommes sur le point de sortir le
label djerba safe pour garantir une île
sans virus de quoi rassurer les gens et
les inciter à venir chez nous le
ministère de la santé va également
publier un communiqué dans ce sens nous
continuerons bien évidemment notre
mission de prévention et nos contrôles
dans l'ensemble du secteur touristique
de l'île
[Musique]
mais également avec les agents
municipaux qu'ils poursuivront leur
mission de désinfection avec tout ça
nous sommes sereins et prêt à accueillir
nos touristes dans les meilleures
conditions avec l'ouverture des
frontières prévue pour le 27 juin le
gouvernement tunisien a annoncé des
mesures strictes à destination des
touristes qui passeront leurs vacances
en tunisie
prise de température protocole sanitaire
ou encore distanciation sociale de quoi
rassurer professionnels et vacanciers et
peut-être sauver une saison qui a très
mal commencé
alors que le secteur touristique annoncé
un manque à gagner de près d'un million
d'euros pour l'année 2020